All of these strategies come from a chapter named "The Devil's Guide To Debugging,"
which was written by a guy named Steve McConnell.
The book is being called Code Complete in 1993 and it encompass all the wisdom
about programming that Steve McConnell had at that time.
What we've seen so far is just three of these rules.
The first one is to scatter output statements everywhere in the code.
Output whatever you want, where you want it, just put it in there such that
you will always be able to figure out what was going on or not.
The second one is to debug the program into existence.
Just keep on adding statements and removing statements until it works.
Never ever backup earlier versions of your code.
I mean who can't remember what he or she has done just 7 minutes ago.
Rule number 4, don't bother understanding what the program should do.
I mean, it's obvious isn't it. If it's not obvious, make it obvious.
My all time favorite though is number 5, use the most obvious fix.
That means fix the symptom instead of the problem.